I would say that my priorities as a
person now is in setting up new ventures
that not for profit making ventures but
designed to tackle some of the major
problems in the world
so I set them up as if they were a
business I set them up like a business I
want them to be entrepreneurial we find
good people to run them we make sure
they're properly funded and then they
set about trying to tackle the purpose
that we set them up for give you one
example before the Iraq war we were
campaigning - so not campaigning we were
trying to see if there was any way that
the war could be avoided and I
approached Nelson Mandela and Kofi Annan
and suggested that if the two of them
went to see Saddam Hussein perhaps using
their moral authority they could
persuade him for the sake of his people
to step down as president and go and
live the rest of his life in Libya and
therefore avoid the invasion and they
agreed to do so the day they would you
to leave the bombing started they never
went but as a result of that we decided
that you know perhaps the world would
benefit from a group of elders properly
geographically spread with with high
moral authority with with the right sort
of gender mix who you know could you
know like it like in an African village
go into conflict situations and knock
heads together and try to resolve those
conflicts and Nelson Mandela and Grusha
Michelle became the elders who the
founding elders they set the oldest up
and asked people like President Carter
and Archbishop Tutu and Mary Robinson
kofi annan and others to become elders
and and over the last couple of years
they've done some some wonderful work
and hopefully in a few hundred years
time they will be still around but we
run that organization just like we run a
business you know with with a great team
of people running it well funded in
order to enable them to do the job of
trying to resolve conflicts
with difficulty but but I you know if
the causes themselves were important
enough I would try to use the power of
persuasion to you know set up the causes
I've tried to use the power of
persuasion to try to find people to to
support those causes and and in a sense
that's you know how I began is that you
know it's a sixteen year old when I left
school very young wanted to start a
magazine too without without finance to
to try to campaign against the
Vietnamese War and other ins justices in
the world you know I had to use my power
of persuasion to get out there and
persuade advertisers and distributors
and others to you know to accept the
magazine or take the magazine and and
you know so you know that was that was
mother started my business and and I
think that you know that if you if
you've got an idea that merits attention
then go and bang on people's doors and
don't accept no for an answer
love life I love listening I love
traveling and I'm learning all the time
you know I think the fact that you know
that the fact that I've gone into so
many different areas you know whether
it's you know aviation whether it's and
trains whether it's space travel whether
it's you know Phillip philanthropic
issues you know I've just spent a
lifetime of learning and and you know I
love to read to you know read good books
about you know global warming issues I
don't just read you know the Tim
Flannery books and the you know the
James Lovelock books I also read books
that have questioning global warming so
I can you know make a you know either
make it make it make it make a proper
calculation on issues but I just love
life so I'd love to live life to its
full and learn all the time